so I just got done doing my face you can
probably see all the makeup on my shirt
but yeah let me get dressed I got the
cutest shirt delivered let me show you I
think that's what I'm going to wear
look at this shirt
[Music]
I am in love with this shirt it's very
comfortable I'm going link down below
where I got it this just Creator who
makes shirts of African countries and
she just did her latest drop which
included Zimbabwe which makes me so
happy cuz
Zimbabwe is seldom included in a lot of
things I see so no I love it um so this
is what we're going to do today we're
applying to our 100th job today we're at
around 79 jobs applied to in the span of
5 days so we're going to apply to 21
More Today Show y'all how I got it to be
like you know clean and crisp so that
you can apply to as many jobs as
possible while still being smart because
quality still matters you know let's
talk about that some more while I make
some food because I am
starving one of the best ways to
personalize your resume so
that each job you apply to gets like the
best version of your resume without
having to spend all that time doing on
each and every job like redoing your
resume for each and every job is by
personalizing your resume for each type
of job you're applying for you can do
this in a number of ways the way that I
decided to do it was do it based on the
role I'm applying for so I am a software
engineer however there are multiple
different niches within software
engineering there's backend engineer
front end engineer there's full stack
there's also ux developers there's Cloud
developers all of those different things
and so I looked at okay what are the
different types of roles that given my
experience and projects and things that
I like to do in general can apply to so
that came down to four
different uh resumés so for me I have a
software engineer SL full stack resume
a
frontend developer
resume a
ux developer
resume and an
iOS mobile developer
resume another way you can do this is by
creating resumés for the industries
you're going to apply to so let's say
you are an iOS Developer and so that is
fully just what you are applying to no
matter what however because of your
experience and background maybe
educational background for me I studied
finance and
whatnot you may find yourself applying
to the same type of job but at different
Industries in finance so fintech Health
Tech mediate Tech Etc
and so you can also create different
resumés of the same job for different
Industries this way now when you apply
to a job you know it's personalized
enough that you can really really go ham
on the applying and spends just a couple
minutes per application without having
to redo your resume each time
[Music]
okay I am finally on my 100th
application this is a good one too it is
for
Lift so let me put everything in here
resume depends what job this is is this
okay software engineer so I'll put my
software engineer resume in
here and we did it we did
it
100 job applications let me put it into
my spreadsheet you
see that's crazy okay hell yeah I'm
going to head back to that couch over
there don't calling my name and rest and
scroll because that took too much time
because I am tired
now okay where my bathroom now because
I've been trying my best to be as active
as possible over the last couple of
months in 2 months I've actually lost
quite a bit bit of weight and really
toned up but I don't feel like going to
the gym which I really haven't felt this
week um probably because I've been going
soam on applying and job hunting i
instead will opt to like walk I'll walk
I'll
walk about 3 and 1/2 to
4ish
Miles and that'll be my finish for the
day I just try my best to just be active
that day in some way I love my
arms pow pow pow pow so yeah let me go
about my walk
[Music]
okay we are back let me show you what I
got it was just a quick
run I needed my
spinach my halo top ice cream which is
literally my favorite ice cream in the
world the entire higher pint is
290 calories and so what I do
is I put it in between some Egos and now
I have a really yummy really low calorie
protein Rich dessert because I don't eat
the whole pint like for an ego I'll do a
third which is like 90
calories so literally the whole I can I
sandwich ends up being about 200
calories I love talinis so I was like
you know what for dinner I have some
leftover Italian sausage pasta sauce
that I'm going to heat up but I'll cook
it with some
talinis and I saw these online um I saw
them as good protein Rich mac and cheese
and I'm not like super big on Mac and
cheese but this just looked really good
and I'm looking for just new ways to
spice up my just meals routine it's
become pretty I don't know pretty
stagnant and I'm trying to yeah I'm
trying to switch it up because that's
also like how you'll be able to stick
with your Fitness routine if like you
eat things that like you like and are
good so hopefully this ends up like the
Halo top and I actually really like it
it should be 14 grams of protein from a
serving and
260 no 15 grams of protein and 280
calories so I'm like no that's really
good that could be a good lunch some
lean ground turkey instead of ground
beef and some potatoes so this is dinner
this is my
evening I'm very excited for it I need
to a gentleman collar
bought these Gorgeous Flowers for me but
look how huge they
are and so I'm going to cut them a
little bit and add them in whatever cute
container I can put inside them
like like they're so pretty so yeah I'm
gonna do that and get along with my
evening overall this was my day and I
feel like it was pretty successful so
thank you so much yeah have a good night
y'all
[Music]